what kind of a dick we working with you
mean you feel good you feel good down
there yeah yeah feels good to me that's
a big dick never what
that was a big dick answer Oh got you
it's a big dick answer you got like you
got a big dick you here's here's like a
regular dick answer you want to do
anybody okay writer cancer house what
kind of Dicky working with all right you
know good well shall we smell the answer
what kind of a what kind of dick we were
I'm laughing in anticipation what kind
of a dick let me do some funny
hold on this is real acting by the way
if it's good that's good Stanislav so
hot I don't know if I could do it he'll
laugh at all that ah mmm okay so this is
small dick Samant dick
what kind of dick you working with good
it's good like no dammit did everyone do
is like everybody thinks they're okay
yeah everybody thinks they're right yeah
same at sex like when you're doing it
like no no dude is can I put this you
think you're back no no all girls think
they're good at [ __ ] and dancing oh
man yeah that's uh you got your me yeah
I'm a girl I'm any girl right say I'm
not crazy about [ __ ] just say that
okay I'm a girl
uh you're mean okay you know I'm not
really crazy about go blow goes oh I
could get about um well it doesn't
matter at that boy because there's no
way I would let that have one acted like
that um names trash
you